(peppy music)
- Right after school I
just like try to like run to the gym,
so I can climb (laughs).
(peppy music)
It's a dangerous sport
but the only thing that I'm afraid of
is not being able to get to the top.
(peppy music)
With climbing I don't think that
it really matters with how big you are.
If you're smaller, you can hold on longer
and your hands might be smaller
so it can fit more fingers on holds.
(peppy music)
I started climbing in Central Park
when I was six years old.
Now I don't think I could like live without it.
(peppy music)
When you're close to the top
of the climb you're trying to do
you forearms usually feel
like they're gonna explode
and they're gonna like burst open.
You feel like you have to let go,
but with climbing you just can't let go.
I think that climbing is,
it's obviously a sport, but
it's also like a dance.
You sort of have to be
able to like flow up the wall
and come up with your own
technique to get to the top.
I think people are
shocked if I do something
that they can't do or something,
because I'm still really
young, and I'm a girl.
So, like, doing something that
even if a guy can't do
is pretty special (laughs).
(peppy music)